[Musique]
unity crew c'est l'histoire d'un groupe
d'amis originaire d'orléans qui ont pour
passion commune la poésie en action et
la musique ses amis organisent des
spectacles collaboratif et inclusif afin
de faire participer les habitants north
les ans pour développer leur esprit
artistique vous allez voir qu'avec eux
la magie des mots se rencontrent sur
scène mais également dans la rue
autrement dit industry
non pas démoniaque de cailloux de rap à
l'ammoniac mais ces familles oui et oui
c'est moi la mise je viens ici
tranquillement proposer un freestyle je
viens de picardie je viens de picardie
je viens de là où les gens vendent du
bétail vivant de du bétail ne ratons pas
détails et si jamais tu es pas content
et mathieu traced urd et albert camus en
improvisation totale s new york
représente
alors ça a commencé quand cette histoire
de 8 6 crew et d'associations date de
naissance de unity crous c'était il ya 5
6 ans maintenant on n'avait pas de flou
n'avait pas de texte on avait eu aucune
maîtrise de la chose mais on a adoré
faire ça et on le faisait on faisait des
cover on prenait des sons qu'on aimait
bien ça a commencé à faire ça dans la
rue à 3 puis de fil en aiguille des gens
nous ont rejoints on a développé des
techniques des contacts trouver des
instrus vous faites de la musique mais
pas que c'est tout un collectif en fait
on est devenus d'un groupe de musique on
est devenu une association en fait le
but de l'association c'est de produire
et de diffuser toutes sortes de musiques
actuelles les gars comme vous le savez
moi je suis dos de france je découvre le
centre val de loire et à ce bateau qui
m'a interpellé qu'est ce que c'est alors
en fait c'est un bateau de marine de
loire s'appelle une gabarre et du coup
c'est un bateau qui était utilisé à
l'époque de la marine de loire pour
transporter tout ce qui ce commerce est
sûre la loire
et c'est resté dans le patrimoine
traditionnel du coin et tout donc t'as
pas mal de passionnés qui continuent
d'utiliser ces bateaux même s'il y'a pus
d'utilisation
commerciale et tout pour ça on peut
avoir vite vite une petite démo de tout
haut à la télé je vois plein de bouffon
derrière l'écran on nous prend pour des
cons loin des illusions des
discriminations nous nous mobilisons car
on a notre mission c'est parce que c'est
propre ça applaudit à la maison jean
thomas 280 policiers
à la fameuse cathédrale d'orléans
alors justement on va continuer à parler
de l'association qu'elles sont un peu
les ambitions pour le futur le prochaine
étape c'est tout simplement d'essayer de
créer des postes ce qui va permettre de
pérenniser justement toutes les actions
qu'on fait déjà et continuer de pouvoir
en accueillir et en créer de nouvelles
et aussi des actions portées vers les
autres on a trouvé l'idée sympathique de
redonner à orléans quelque chose
d'écologique en tournant sur l'anti
gaspillage en récupérant glanant des
fins de marché des produits qui sont
voit la destruction alors qu'ils sont
encore tout à fait comestible pour
distribuer gratuitement les denrées
alimentaires qu'on récupère dans les
samedis matin et vendredi soir et tout
est gratuit et qui venait donc les
étudiantes et étudiants des cadres des
sdf on a vraiment un peu tout et bien
les gars mieux les tic roues merci merci
pour cette visite et cette balade cette
découverte et merci
courir chez stx merci pour la rendre
c'est le disent les jeunes je vous donne
de la force ici la fois en france